(rock music)
- All right, every day I enjoy
picking out something cool
from social media to share
in case you may have overlooked it.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
Some kids just know from early on
what they're going to be in
life, what they want to be.
And for me, singing was,
there was no other option.
I was definitely screwed
if it wasn't singing.
For a Michigan woman,
paleontology was the right choice for her.
It's a decision she made
when she was seven years old
visiting the dinosaur exhibit
at the Field Museum in Chicago.
And recently, she celebrated
just how far she's come since then
sharing a photo of her
first trip to the museum
alongside a photo of her
now doing research there,
which is so incredible.
We have her on the line right
now watching on WXYZ TV.
Everybody say hello to Lynnea.
(audience clapping)
Hi.
- Hi.
- Oh my God, first of all,
I love the photos next to each other.
So, what was your first visit there like?
- So the first photo, I was
on a vacation to Chicago
with my parents and we
visited the Field Museum
where they had this exhibit
that was basically just this giant sandbox
that was filled with bones,
so you could go dig up your own dinosaur.
And there was someone there to explain
what paleontology even is.
And I think that was the first time
that I even learned what a dinosaur was.
So I was like, oh my god, that's so cool.
That's what I wanna be when I grow up.
And then there was this station
where you could make a model of the bone.
So my mom took this like extremely
goofy looking photo of me
and that's how that happened.
- I love it.
So explain it like in the next picture,
like you're going back
and now you're a researcher in this field
that you've wanted to
do when you were seven.
That's so cool.
What was that full circle moment like?
- Yeah, so I grew up
and then I decided that I was
gonna be a paleontologist.
So, I did a master's at
University of Minnesota
and my advisor for my master's
was actually the curator
from the Field Museum.
And he was the same guy who
helped create that exhibit
that first got me
interested in paleontology.
So, everything kind of came full circle.
And then we did a research visit.
So, we went back to the collections
and I was thinking, this is incredible.
And I showed him that goofy photo of me
and he thought it was hilarious.
So he went and grabbed
the exact same fossil
and then he said, "Here, you
have to recreate this photo."
So then, I did and I posted it
and everyone else thought
it was equally goofy.
- No, it's so cool.
And to dream something, you know,
that's a really cool
thing to dream as a kid
and then actually for it to
come to fruition is incredible.
Congratulations.
- Thank you so much.
(audience clapping)
- Yeah.
Well, thank you so much, Lynnea,
I'm liking your post right now.
And that's not all.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like you, ma'am.
So they're gonna be giving
you a check for $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience clapping)
- [Lynnea] Oh my God.
- I love it.
Thank you so much, Lynnea.
And you to all our guests this hour:
Martha Stewart, Candace Parker,
(audience clapping drowns out Kelly)
Y'all have a great day, and if
it's not, try and change it.